welcome to exploring computing
today's video is control structures
conditionals
so in the previous lecture we talked
about how
when we have a program we have a number
of statements that we've written and the
computer will follow our directions and
we'll execute the statements in the
order in which they're listed
and that's what we usually what we want
to have happen in our simpler programs
but
sometimes we want a little bit more
control over which statements get
executed
and we can do this using something
called a control structure a control
structure determines the order of
execution so
there are a number of different types of
control structures and depending upon
the specific type of control structure
the control structure may cause
statements to execute in some situations
but not others
it may cause the computer to execute
statements a given number of times
it may cause the execution of statements
over and over and over again until a
particular condition occurs
and we will be looking at several
different types of control structures
the ones that we're going to be talking
about today fall into a category called
conditional control structures
the simplest conditional control
structures execute code if a particular
condition is true
and otherwise they don't do anything a
slightly fancier version which we'll
also talk about today
execute code of a particular condition
is true and execute some other
different code if that condition is
false and then finally
there are some conditional control
structures that will execute different
code
depending upon the value of a particular
variable so for example if a variable is
currently set to one
one set of code will get executed at
that variable set to two a different set
of code will get executed in a variable
set to three a third
set of code will get executed if you
actually look at that last
uh example there you may realize that we
could probably do that
by using one of the previous two sets of
control structures
and this is something that actually
happens quite often in computer science
where there are more primitive
mechanisms that can be used to implement
the more sophisticated mechanisms but
i'm using the more sophisticated
mechanisms generally it's going to make
it easier for people to understand
what's going on and easier to read
so let's take a look at our first
control structure
which is the if statement and so here's
some code here with an if statement
and i'm going to be using temperature
examples for today's lecture
so i'm going to go ahead and get a
temperature from the user
and and then i'm going to have the
computer give its opinion on what it
thinks to this temperature
so this code pretty much you could
probably look at this code and figure
out what it's doing
so it retrieves the temperature from the
user using the input statement and then
you'll recall we need to convert that
because generally the input statement is
going to return a string which will be
treated as text
and in this case we want to treat it as
a number and so we're going to convert
it to a floating point number
and then we're going to compare that
floating point number which we are
storing in the variable
or storage location which we have named
temperature and if that temperature is
greater than 90 degrees we're going to
print
it's too hot so let's take a look at the
syntax of this if statement
and so you can see here i've got the
word if
this is what is sometimes referred to as
a keyword it is a word that has specific
meaning in python
it's also sometimes referred to as a
reserved word because
you cannot name a variable if so if you
were to name a variable if the computer
would get very confused
if you're familiar with the old uh comic
routine
comedy routine who's on first that's the
sort of situation you would get into
all right so we're gonna write down the
word if
and then we're gonna have some sort of a
test condition and i will take a look at
the
sorts of test conditions we can have a
little bit later we're going to follow
that by a colon
and then we are going to have an
indented
statement or set of statements
and then after we're done with our
indented statements we're going to have
some additional statements after that or
we may have some additional statements
after that
and so this the way this works is the
test condition
should give us a true false value we're
going to take again we're going to take
a closer look at that in a minute and so
our our test condition was if the
temperature is greater than 90 and
you think about temperature greater than
90 so either the temperature is greater
than 90 or it's less than or equal to
90. so that's a true false value
so either one condition is true or the
other condition is true and that's what
we want for our test conditions
if that test condition is true in fact
the
temperature is greater than 90 then what
we're going to do is we're going to
execute the statements that are
indented below that if test condition
in our case it's going to do the print
statement it's too hot
and then if we have additional
statements that we want to always
execute those would go after
the other statements let's take a look
at a slightly more complex example
okay so in this case i've got a number
of statements that get
always executed so essentially the thing
to be paying attention to
is in python the indentation of the
statements
determines which statements are
subordinate to other statements so i've
got that temperature equals float
input enter temperature that always
happens
the print computers are heat sensitive
that always happens
the if temperature is greater than 90
that always happens and if we go all the
way down to the bottom the
print be nice to your computer that also
always happens
but there's two intermediate statements
the print it's too hot
and print your computer won't be happy
those are only going to occur
if the test condition in our if
statement which is temperatures greater
than 90
is true if the temperature is less than
or equal to 90
then those two print statements that are
indented the it's too hot and your
computer won't be happy
those will not be printed so that's
that's our if statement
okay as i suggested earlier uh sometimes
there are times when we will want to
execute one set of statements if a
condition is true and a second set of
statements
if the condition is false and so that's
what the if else
variant of the if statement gives us and
so you could probably again look at this
and figure out what it's doing
so again we're going to get the
temperature from the user and if the
temperature is greater than 90
i'm going to say it's too hot and
otherwise i'm going to print it's okay
and i should mention here i sort of
briefly alluded to this a little bit
earlier but
let's talk about it explicitly notice
that
when you are doing a comparison like
this you need to think about
if something is greater than something
you also need to think about it as less
than something you also need to consider
what's gonna happen if it's equal to
something so
in this case if the temperature is
exactly 90 degrees
i'm going to print it's okay all right
here's the syntax for
our if-else statement so i have if
followed by test condition
followed by colon don't forget that
colon that colon is super important if
you skip the colon
uh python's going to be really unhappy
with you and you have a syntax error and
it's not going to run
okay if test condition colon and then i
have that
indentation and then i have a one or
more statements
that i want to carry out if the test
condition is true and so
you know how does python know which
statements to execute if the condition
is true
it's whatever statements are indented
after the if statement
okay then there's the else and again
there's a colon there don't forget the
colon
and then i have one or more statements
indented after
the else and those will all get executed
if the statement
if the test condition is false and then
if i have additional statements which
aren't indented those will always get
executed
i can also chain my if statements
together i don't think this has an
official name but i call them chaining
if else statements
so you can see in this case i'm checking
what the temperature is
i'm printing if computers are heat
sensitive i'm
checking the temperatures greater than
90 and we've seen this before
and then i have that l if temperatures
greater than 80
l if temperature is greater than 65 else
print it's cold computers like it nice
and cold
all right so the idea here is
it's going to try and carry out that
temperature is greater than 90
comparison and if the temperature is
greater than 90
it's going to go ahead and print it's
too hot and your computer won't be happy
and then it will skip all the way down
to the
print statement there so the ls
lf else will all get ignored if that
first test condition temperature is
greater than 90 is
true if temperature is less than or
equal to 90
then it's going to do the test condition
in that first l
if temperature is greater than 80. if
that test condition is true
it's going to print it's warm and then
after it's done printing it's warm it's
going to ignore the lf below it and it's
going to ignore the else below it and go
down all the way to
print be nice to your computer if the
temperature is
less than or equal to 80 it's going to
do the next test condition it's going to
check whether or not the temperature is
greater than 65
and if that test condition is true it'll
print it's nice your computer's fine
uh and then it's going to skip the else
statement and it will go directly to the
print be nice to your computer
on the other hand if the temperature is
less than or equal to 65
it will print it's cold computers like
it nice and cold and then it will
always print be nice to your computer so
it is possible to do this without
chaining these together
but it's going to be a lot messier
because if
i want to print it's warm
without the lf there i'm going to have
to both
check that the temperature is greater
than 80 but i'm also going to have to
check that the temperature is
in fact less than or equal to 90 because
otherwise it's going to print both it's
too hot
and it's warm so um
these lifts are actually pretty handy
even though this syntax structure looks
a lot lot messier
okay so here's the general syntax
structure for our
chained elsifs if test condition
colon and then a bunch of statements if
it's true
and then uh if that test condition is
true it jumps all the way to the end
after the if after the lf i don't have
an else in this case but if it were
to end with an else it would be after
the else and it would go all the way
down to other statements
if the test condition is false it goes
to the lf
and it has a second test condition um if
that second test condition is false if
i've got another l if
that third test condition would get
checked uh there was another left that
fourth test condition would get checked
and then you can either end with an lf
and if that last test condition
is still false none of the statements
get executed or you can end this with an
else either one works
all right let's take a look at those
test conditions i mentioned earlier
so basically what we want with our test
condition is something that returns
either a
true or false value so temperatures
greater than 90 this
is what we refer to as a comparison or
the greater than is a comparison
or a comparator operator um and
it results in a true false value a true
false value in computer science is
often referred to as a boolean value and
this is actually named after a person
there was a mathematician named george
bull who came up with a
set of mathematics based on true false
values at the time it wasn't considered
really important
but uh this was before we had computers
and now it's the basis of computing so
um
go george boole uh here are some test
conditions you can use so there's the
greater than
i mentioned that you need to think about
what happens when something's equal so
you can either say hey this is only true
if it's greater so temperature is
greater than 90 or you can be like
hey i think a temperature of 90 is
pretty bad too so
i'm still using greater than which says
you know the temperature is 90 that
doesn't count it's only if it's greater
than 90 or you can use the greater than
or equal
now um if you've seen mathematically
there is a greater than
or equal with the underscore under the
greater than we don't use that computer
science
instead we've used the greater than sign
followed by the equal sign because it's
easier to type
um that greater than or equal to uh
there's no way to type it on a standard
keyboard you have to do something
special to get that going
there's less than there's less than or
equal there's
two equal signs which means the two
values are the same as each other
this equal single equal sign would be a
variable assignment and we don't want to
do that
and then there's a not equals which is
created by using the exclamation point
by an equals this would be like
hey i like any temperature except for
80 degrees if it's 81 degrees that's
great if it's
79 degrees that's great but if it is
equal to 80 that's a problem so i would
use the not equal
to sort of signify that
okay so here's an example a different
example here using one of the other
comparison operators so if
age is greater than or equal to 18 then
print
you can vote otherwise print you're too
young to vote
now we can combine these together this
does get a little bit messy so you do
need to be careful when you're using
these but they can be quite handy
so if i wanted to check that the
temperature is between the range of 70
and 85 i can do that
by combining two comparisons i can
compare the temperature and make sure
it's greater than or equal 70
and i can also compare the temperature
and make sure it's less than or equal to
85 and so i'm combining these together
with an
and this is only going to be true
this print i like this weather is only
going to get printed
if the temperature is both greater than
or equal to 70 and
it is also less than or equal to 85.
this is what is referred to as a boolean
operator because it
combines two boolean values remember our
true false values
are things that result in true false
values those are called boolean values
um there's also or operators so uh in
the second example here i've got an or i
say if the temperature is less than 50
or if the temperature is greater than 95
then
print two extremes so my or operator is
going to work if either
one of the test conditions is true so
either
the temperature is less than 50 or if
the temperature is greater than 95 then
the whole thing will be true and we will
print too extreme
there's also not operator it's a little
bit it's probably used a bit less
frequently
and it's probably a bit harder to
understand but
basically it takes whatever comes after
it and inverts it so
before we had if the age was greater
than or equal to 18
people could vote and maybe people are
looking at the results of our
previous uh election and thinking that
hey i don't think we did so good with
people great on their equal 18 voting so
maybe we're just going to invert that so
we're going to say
if not age is greater than 18 and so
we'll have three-year-olds voting
and so if i if i do if not age is
greater than equal to 18
this essentially means that if the age
is 18 or
over that comparison age greater than
equal to 18 is true but then not
actually reverses that so
basically if somebody is 17.9
they would be able to vote if people
were 16 they would be able to vote if
they were three they would be able to
vote
but if they're 18 19 20 50
70 they couldn't vote all right
it's also possible to just put a boolean
value straight there
so we can write boolean values as true
and false
in in python these are written with a
capital t so if
true print i like this weather this
actually always prints i like this
weather
you wouldn't use this in an if statement
but there are some other control
structures where some people do
like using this particular uh method of
always
always putting a true value there i
personally think it's a little odd i
i do know there are reasons why they do
it but uh but you will see the serve
code you won't see it with an if
statement
so again i've just written a boolean
value there directly
and so this is always going to be true
and so it's always going to print i like
this weather
and you can also take these boolean
values and
just store them into variables directly
so
you know we've previously talked about
how there are integer values
they're floating point values and
they're strings and it turns out boolean
is yet another type of value
that we can store in in a variable
that we can assign into variables that
we have operators that operate
on them just the same way we have
integers
that we can store into variables we can
use an operators we can add and subtract
them and so on
and so we'll see more of these in the
next lecture all right that's it for
today
i'll talk to y'all soon